i also don't want my drink to be my meal  i like a meal i like a drink but i don't  want my drink to be my meal i would  drink every single meal if i could  everything you don't really want to be  chewing and  chewing is a  massive waste of time and energy  mix it with my saliva and swallow it  that's it that's it well the way you  chew it is a waste of time though  there's a lot of chewing there's  compartmentalizing of the food  i hate the way it  it sits there for a while or something  else is chewed and moved up into the top  of your mouth then at some point  factory  assembly line  you're  is  the egg from the salt in your mouth  somehow  because you've learned what whole  metabolized fat is so right now you are  turning food into a liquid in your mouth  mouth is the ultimate blender